we've discovered more about the world
than any other civilization before us
[Music]
but we have been stuck on this one
problem
how do proteins fold up how
do proteins go from a string of amino
acids to a compact
shape that acts as a machine and drives
life
when you find out about proteins it is
very exciting you could think of them as
little biological
nano machines they have essentially the
fundamental
building blocks that power everything
living on this planet
if we can reliably predict protein
structures using ai
that could change the way we understand
the natural world
protein folding is one of these holy
grail
type problems in biology we've always
hypothesized that ai should be helpful
to make these kinds of big scientific
breakthroughs more quickly
and then i'll probably be looking at
little tunings that might make a
difference
you should be creating this distagram
one and a background discussion
we've been working on our system alpha
fold really hard now for over two years
rather than having to do painstaking
experiments in the future biologists
might be able to
instead rely on ai methods to directly
predict structures quickly and
efficiently
generally speaking biologists tend to be
quite skeptical
of computational work and i think that
skepticism is healthy and i respect it
but i feel very excited about what alpha
phil can achieve
casp is when we we say look deep mind is
doing protein folding
this is how good we are and maybe it's
better than everybody else maybe it
isn't
we decided to enter casp competition
because it represented
the olympics of protein folding casp
we started to try and speed up
the solution to the protein folding
problem when we started
cass in 1994 i certainly was naive
about how hard this was going to be it
was very cumbersome to do that because
it took a long time
let's see what were we doing still to
improve typically a hundred different
groups from around the world participate
in casp
and we take a set of 100 proteins and we
ask the groups to
send us what they think the structures
look like we can reach 57.9 gdt
on cast 12 ground truths casp has a
metric on which you will be scored
which is this gdt metric on a scale of 0
to 100
you would expect a gdt over 90 to be
a solution to the problem if we do
achieve this this has incredible medical
relevance the implications are immense
from how diseases progress
how you can discover new drugs it's
endless
i wanted to make a really simple system
and the results have been surprisingly
good the team
got some results with a new technique
not only is it more accurate but it's
much faster than the old system
i think we'll uh substantially exceed
what we're doing right now because then
it's a game
game changer i think in casp 13
something very significant had happened
for the first time
we saw the effective application of
artificial intelligence
we've advanced the state of the art in
the field so that's fantastic but we
still have a long way to go before we've
solved it
the shapes were now approximately
correct for many of the proteins
but the details exactly where each atom
sits which is really what one would call
a solution
were not yet there it doesn't help if
you have the tallest ladder when you're
going to the moon
we hit a little bit of a brick wall
since we won casp
then it was back to the drawing board
and like what are our new ideas
um and then it's taking a little while i
would say for them to get back to where
they were but with the new ideas
and then now i think we're seeing the
benefits of the new ideas
they can go further right so that's a
really important moment i've seen that
moment so many times
now but i know what that means now and i
know this is the time now to press we
need to double down and go
as fast as possible from here i think
we've got no time to lose
so the intention is to enter casp again
casp is deeply stressful
there's something weird going on with
the learning because it is
learning something that's correlated
with gdt but it's not calibrated
i feel slightly uncomfortable we should
be learning this you know in the blink
of an eye
the technology advancing outside deep
mind is also doing incredible work and
there's always the possibility
another team has come somewhere out left
field that we don't even know about
someone asked me well should we panic
now of course we should have been
panicking before
it does seem to do better but still
doesn't do quite as well it's the best
model
so it looks like there's room for
improvement there's always a risk that
you've missed something and that's why
blind assessments like casp are so
important to validate whether our
results are real
obviously i'm excited to see how casp14
goes my expectation is
we get our heads down we focus on the
full goal which is to solve the whole
problem
the prime minister has announced the
most drastic limits to our lives that
the uk
has ever seen in living memory i must
give the british people
a very simple instruction you must stay
at home
[Music]
we were prepared for casp to start on
april 15th because that's when it was
originally scheduled to start
and it's been delayed by a month due to
coronavirus
i really miss everyone i struggled a
little bit just kind of getting into a
routine
especially with my wife she came down
with the virus
i mean luckily it didn't turn out too
serious casp started
on monday can i just check this diagram
you've got here john this one where we
ask ground truth is this one we've done
badly on we're actually
quite good on this region if you imagine
that we hadn't have said it came around
this way but had put it
down instead yeah one of the hardest
proteins we've gotten in casp thus far
is a source cove two protein uh called
orphan
orth8 is a coronavirus protein we tried
really hard to improve our projection
like really really hard probably the
most time that we have ever spent on a
single target
so we're about two thirds of the way
through casp
and we've gotten three answers back we
now have a ground truth for all
eight which is one of the coronavirus
proteins
and it turns out we did really well in
predicting that
amazing job everyone the whole team it's
been an incredible
effort here what we saw in casp14 was a
group
delivering atomic accuracy off the bat
essentially solving what in our world is
two problems
how do you look to find the right
solution and then how do you recognize
you've got the right solution when
you're there all right are we
are we mostly here i'm going to read an
email
uh i got this from john malt
and i'll just read it says john as i
expect you know
your group has performed amazingly well
in casp 14
both relative to other groups and an
absolute model accuracy
congratulations on this work it is
really outstanding
alpha fold represents a huge leap
forward that i hope will
really accelerate drug discovery and
help us to better understand disease
it's pretty mind-blowing you know these
results were
for me having worked on this problem so
long
after many many stops and starts and
will this ever get there
suddenly this is a solution we'd solve
the problem
this gives you such excitement about the
way science works about how you can
never see
exactly or even approximately what's
going to happen next
there are always these surprises and
that really as a scientist is what keeps
you going what's the going to be the
next surprise
[Music]